Anie Samson, Luc Ferrandez,
bonsoir. Ça ne peut pas être
plus chaud. J'ai disais après
notre sondage de la semaine
dernière, mais là, celui-là,
Jean-Marc Léger a dit dans le
Journal de Montréal, ce matin,
le dernier sondage aussi chaude
que celui le référendum de 95.
Qu'est-ce que ça vous dit sur
l'allure de la cause, est-ce que
quelqu'un a en même temps,
quelqu'un rattrape un autre?
Qu'est-ce que vous en déduisez
de ces chiffres? Balarama
Holness sept à 12.
- Ce que samedi, ceux qui sont
encore tête, reste encore 10
jours, chaque paramètre
important, chaque faux pas va
paraître encore plus. Les deux
ont à aller chercher encore
chaque vote parce que un vote
peut faire la différence,
surtout dans cette campagne.
Pour ce qui est de Balarama
Holness, 12 %, il va aller
chercher saupoudrer des votes un
peu partout dans la clientèle
anglophone, pas assez pour avoir
un candidat ou un élu, mais il
va aller en chercher un peu, et
ça fait mal à l'équipe de Denis
Coderre, selon les sondages dans
l'ouest de la ville, si les
allophones, les anglophones.
- Les gens qui ne voteraient pas
pour Valérie Plante.
- Exactement, c'est 12 %, est-ce
que les gens vont changer d'idée
en allant voter, on ne sait pas
encore, mais c'est assez
palpitant, puis je gagerais pas
encore une pièce sur le
vainqueur pour l'instant.
- C'est vrai que je retrouve un
peu mon coup parce que...
- vous aviez dit : plante haut
la main.
- Plus Balarama Holness se
montre, plus plante va monter.
Je me suis pas trompé. Mais je
suis surpris de voir les
qualités perdurer aussi
longtemps. Si M. Coderre grâce à
Balarama Holness. Si j'étais un
des deux, je concentrerai toutes
mes énergies dans quatre
arrondissements : rivière des
Prairies Pointe-aux-Trembles,
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve, Saint-
Michel Villeret Parc-Extension
et surtout notre de Grasse Côte-
des-Neiges, c'est là que ça va
durer. Dans une course serrée,
validant les arrondissements où
rien n'est déterminé, juste deux
de ses arrondissements,
350 000 votes. C'est là qu'il
faut aller, mettre les efforts.
- Est-ce que vous notez que les
deux campagnes ont pris leur
rythme et il n'y a pas eu de
gaffe majeure, il n'y a pas
eu... M. Coderre, lors du débat
chez nous cette semaine était
plutôt calme, Mme Plante aussi,
ils ont exposé leurs idées, M.
Coderre revient beaucoup sur la
fluidité des camions depuis
quelques jours, est-ce que vous
comprenez ce qu'ils veulent
faire?
- Évidemment, ils vont arriver
avec des dossiers beaucoup plus
précis parce qu'on le disait
pendant la campagne, c'était
évasif, le grand public, ils
vont toucher là où les gens sont
intéressés, ou ça les dérange,
et je reviens un peu sur ce que
le disais, effectivement, les
deux gros arrondissements qui
vont être les plus importants,
Côte-des-Neiges et Villeray
Saint-Michel, la clientèle là-
bas et multiculturelle,
les deux ans arrondissements les
plus multiculturelles à
Montréal, il y a des
anglophones, des allophones et
évidemment les francophones,
dont évidemment tout ce qui
touche le petit pourcentage qui
va les différencier sont là.
- Est-ce qu'il y a un thème qui
ressort ou pas vraiment?
- Je ne pense pas, mais ça
change d'un sondage, le premier
c'est l'habitation, le deuxième
c'est l'environnement et le
troisième c'est la sécurité. Ma
Valérie Plante alors qu'il est;
elle doit faire des annonces sur
ce ces deux thèmes principaux,
Denis Coderre va frapper sur le
clou de la sécurité, vient de
sortir des affiches uniquement
dédiées à la sécurité. Après
avoir fait ces annonces, c'est
du travail de brah, de l'huile
Decon, pour faire sortir le
vote, les machines pour faire
sortir le vote. Chaque vote
compte, ce n'est pas comme au
provincial, pour les députés et
le nombre de députés va
déterminer le premier ministre.
Tandis qu'au municipal que tu
peux perdre, mais si tu veux
aller chercher 10 de plus, ces
votes vont à la mairesse ou
mère. C'est pour ça qu'il faut
travailler fort.
- Qui a la meilleure machine
pour faire sortir le vote?
- Je te en fonction de la
clientèle qui va voter, la
clientèle Denis Coderre, c'est
une clientèle plus âgée qui
connaît l'importance du vote, le
droit d'aller voter et qui vont
voter. Donc, la machine
habituellement, si on va
chercher les personnes les plus
âgées, on leur offre le
transport, le téléphone, la
machine fonctionne comme ça
parce qu'on a toujours fait des
élections de cette façon,
s'imprégner dans l'image du
parti. Pour ce qui est de
l'équipe de Mme Plante, c'est un
parti qui est plus jeune, la
passion est différente, plus
moderne, est-ce que les jeunes
vont aller voter? Il est là le
défi, parce que c'est la
clientèle qui vote à 25 %, des
gens qui vont aller voter dans
les gènes. La question est : qui
va aller voter, comment va
sortir, est-ce que les gens
voyaient aller parce que c'est
là que ça va faire la
différence, peu importe s'ils
sont à égalité aujourd'hui,
c'est là que ça se joue.
- Dans les quartiers centraux,
les gens qui vont voter pour
Valérie Plante, Plateau Mont-
Royal, Rosemont, le centre-
ville, sont déjà déterminés à
aller voter. Alors, ça ne donne
rien de les appeler quatre fois.
Ce qu'il faut viser travailler
sur ceux qui sont en dehors des
quartiers centraux parce que là
ça va se jouer. Or, en dehors
des quartiers centraux, Projet
Montréal et moyen-fort.
- Vous avez vu nos deux
reportages, exemple de Saint-
Jean-sur-Richelieu, Mont-
Tremblant, on veut développer
des maisons de ville, c'est
partout, ça doit faire plaisir
quand même qu'on entend plus, il
y a des camps qui s'affrontent,
on dit les choses.
- Absolument, justement, j'ai
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
m'envoyer beaucoup de
documentation les cinquièmes ils
font campagne, il y a aussi des
travailleurs, reste très peu de
boisé, on veut continuer de
développer, il y a plus
d'intérêt à développer, c'est du
terrien agricole, des milieux
humides ou dboisés. Quand on dit
qu'il faut atteindre
l'équilibre, viser l'équilibre
entre développement économique
et doublement des terrains, il a
déjà été dépassé depuis
longtemps et c'est la même chose
à tremblant. Le mot d'ordre
devrait être protégé ce qui est
vert, il faut que les mères qui
se présentent veuillent protéger
ce qui est vert, je leur
souhaite la chance au monde.
- Ce qui est vraiment
intéressant, c'est que les
électeurs ont un pouvoir, le
zonage, c'est le conseil
municipal qui décide si oui ou
non au développement, ce n'est
pas Québec ni Ottawa, ce sont
les citoyens qui vont décider de
leur environnement.
- Exactement, puis j'ai toujours
dit que les citoyens sont les
patrons des élus, donc ce sont
les citoyens qui décident ce
qu'ils veulent. Le gros défi,
surtout Mont-Tremblant, c'est le
financement des villes, 75 % du
budget des villes viennent des
taxes foncières, par contre,
faut pas non plus sacrifier nos
idéologies, ces organes Mont-
Tremblant, pourquoi on va là?
Parce que c'est beau, sévère,
c'est un village, c'est
intéressant. Ça devient comme
une petite ville, ça va perdre
son cachet, donc Mont-Tremblant
a intérêt à garder le cachet
pour avoir ces touristes parce
que je pense qu'ils vivent quand
même de bons revenus avec la
quantité de...
c'est pas plus fort que tout,
c'est pas ça qui est difficile.
- L'attrait des taxes...
je pense qu'ils ont eu l'attrait
des taxes, les taxes à Mont-
Tremblant sont gigantesques
comparativement à un éventuel
village. Le problème, c'est que
les gens qui vont, là où il y a
le plus d'électeurs, c'est le
village de Mont-Tremblant, et
les gens du resort ne votent pas
puisque ce sont des touristes
qui passent. Les gens du village
veulent avoir du développement,
les gens autour du resort
s'arrête. C'est très difficile,
la tension monte beaucoup.
- Et partout sur le territoire,
beaucoup de municipalités, la
question de la protection du
territoire est devenue
importante dans l'élection.
Le vous en parliez depuis
longtemps, mais on dirait que
c'est réel.
- Regardez les deux grandes
villes autres Montréal,
Longueuil, la campagne est de
protéger tous les espaces, à
Laval : protéger les rives.
Il y a un candidat qui opposait
de proposer l'école, mais il
n'est pas là. J'espère que...
- M. Plande?
- Le maire de Saint-Jean-sur-
Richelieu s'appelle M. Lapla